BUCKLE UP.
TONIGHT FROM D.C., THE OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
TODAY I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
WITNESS THE BRAVERY AND COURAGE
OF OUR SOLDIERS AS I TRAVELED
WITH FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP,
AND TO THE AWE-INSPIRING
AIRCRAFT CARRIER WHERE HE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN WITH
OUR FIRST LADY.
>> STAY TRUE TO MYSELF, YOU USE
THAT TERM A LOT.
WHY DON'T YOU EXPAND ON THAT A
LITTLE?
>> I DO WHAT I THINK IS RIGHT.
I KNOW I LIKE AT THE CRITICISM
FROM THE PUBLIC OR FROM THE
MEDIA BUT I WILL DO WHAT IS
RIGHT AND WHAT I FEEL IS RIGHT
FOR THE COUNTRY AND FOR THE
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHAT I SAY.
I WILL STAY TRUE TO MYSELF AND
LISTEN TO MYSELF AND WHAT TO DO,
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG.
AND DELETING A MEANINGFUL LIFE
EVERY DAY.
>> Sean: WE WILL HAVE THAT
FULL INTERVIEW IN A FEW MINUTES
ALONG WITH SOME PLANES LANDING
AND TAKING OFF.
FIRST WE HAVE UPDATES ON THE
MUELLER PARTISAN WITCH HUNT.
LYING TO CONGRESS ABOUT BUILDING
A BUILDING PROJECT THAT NEVER
EVEN GOT OFF THE GROUND AND A
QUESTIONABLE CAMPAIGN BOOK
FINANCE VIOLATION.
NOTICE SOMETHING MISSING?
NO TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLISION.
NONE COME AGAIN.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
MICHAEL COHEN DOES NOT HAVE A
PROSECUTION AGREEMENT WITH
PROSECUTORS.
ANOTHER TOP TARGET, MICHAEL
FLYNN IS ASKING A FEDERAL JUDGE
FOR LENIENCY AND NO JAIL TIME.
HE PLED GUILTY TO LYING TO
INVESTIGATORS BUT ONLY AFTER
LEGAL BILLS WRECKED HIS FAMILY
FINANCES AND FORCE THIS, 33
YEARS A VETERAN IN FIVE YEARS OF
COMBAT TO HAVE TO SELL HIS HOME
AND PROBABLY WAS MOST LIKELY
SETTING PUNITIVE ACTION AGAINST
HIS SON AND BUSINESS PARTNER.
HE FELL ON THE SWORD LIKE
PROBABLY 99% OF OTHERS WOULD DO.
AND TONIGHT WE ARE LEARNING
DISCUSSING THE DETAILS
SURROUNDING HOW
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN
WAS TREATED BY TOP FEDERAL
OFFICIALS.
ACCORDING TO THE SENTENCING
REQUEST, THEN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE PRESSURED
ADVISOR FLYNN NOT TO HAVE A
LAWYER PRESENT DURING A
SEEMINGLY RELAXED, CASUAL
MEETING WITH THE FBI.
THE ONE THAT HE THEY SAID HE
LIED OUT EXCEPT NOBODY BELIEVES
HE LIED.
HE SAT DOWN WITH NO ATTORNEYS
PRESENT AND WAS CHARGED WITH
LYING TO HER IN THAT VERY
MEETING.
KEEP IN MIND ANDREW McCABE WAS
FIRED FROM THE FBI FOR HIM LYING
TO THE BUREAU AND HE'S CURRENTLY
FACING NO CHARGES.
ACCORDING TO FoxNews.com, THE
FILING SEEMINGLY DEMONSTRATES
THAT THE FBI TOOK A
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE AGGRESSIVE
TACK IN HANDLING THE FLYNN
INTERVIEW THAN IT DID DURING
OTHER SIMILAR MATTERS.
FOR EXAMPLE, "NO ONE INTERVIEWED
DURING THE FBI'S CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION WAS HIT WITH A
FALSE STATEMENT CHARGES.
ALTHOUGH INVESTIGATORS BELIEVED
THOSE WITNESSES WERE UNTRUTHFUL.
BIG DIFFERENCE.
AS WE NOW KNOW THAT'S CALLED THE
TWO-TIER JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND THIS MIGHT BE THE WORST PART
OF FLYNN'S POLITICAL
PERSECUTION, THE AGENTS
INTERVIEWING FLYNN, THEY NEVER
THOUGHT HE LIED.
THAT IS SUCH A MISCARRIAGE OF
JUSTICE AND AN ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IN AMERICAN HISTORY, AS
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU.
AND OF COURSE YOU ARE NOT LIKELY
TO HEAR ABOUT ANY OF THIS ON ANY
OTHER MEDIA, ESPECIALLY OVER AT
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC FOR THE HOST
LITERALLY SPEND EVERY SINGLE
DAY, SPENT HOURS TRYING TO OUTDO
THEMSELVES TRADING INSULTS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, THE TRUMP FAMILY
AND ANYBODY ASSOCIATED WITH
TRUMP.
IT'S A PRETTY SAD AND SCARY WAY
TO START YOUR MORNING BUT TODAY,
THE COHOST OF MIKA BREZINSKI
WENT TOO FAR AND USE THIS
DISGUSTING SLUR JUST BEFORE
9:00 A.M.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T CARE.
BUT WHY DOESN'T MIKE POMPEO CARE
RIGHT NOW?
ARE THE PATHETIC AFFLICTIONS
THAT WE JUST HEARD WHEN HE
APPEARED ON FOX & FRIENDS, IS
THAT A PATRIOT SPEAKING?
OR A WANT TO BE DICTATOR'S BOY?
I'M DEAD SERIOUS.
I'M ASKING, ARE THESE THE WORDS
OF A PATRIOT?
AS BEING ONE UP QUESTIONING HIS
PATRIOTISM, UNBELIEVABLE AND
OVER THE TOP.
THEN SHE ISSUED A APOLOGY ON
TWITTER ABOUT HER LANGUAGE.
SOME BAD CHOICES IN LANGUAGE, I
SHOULD HAVE SAID WATER BOY, LIKE
FOR A FOOTBALL TEAM.
YES, BAD CHOICE OF WORDS.
BUT WE ARE CONSISTENT ON THIS
PROGRAM.
WE DON'T CALL FOR BOYCOTTS OR
FIRINGS OF ANY KIND.
IN FACT WHEN SHE WAS IN HOT
WATER OVER A CONSPIRACY FILLED
BLOG THAT SHE HAD, WE NEVER
CALLED FOR HER TO BE FIRED OR
PER SHOW TO BE BOYCOTTED.
PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES AND WHAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT PERFECT AND I
DON'T BELIEVE ANYONE'S CAREER,
IN MY HONEST OPINION, SHOULD BE
RUINED OVER A STUPID MISTAKE.
AND BY THE WAY SHE'S NO FAN OF
MINE AND NEITHER IS LIBERAL JOE.
THERE WERE MANY WARNING SIGNS AS
THE ANTI-TRUMP VITRIOL GOT WORSE
AND WORSE AND WORSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS STUNNINGLY IGNORANT.
>> NO.
>> HE IS IGNORANT AND WARPED,
OBSESSED WITH MONEY AND.
HE FINDS HIS POWER IN THOSE TWO
THINGS.
HE WILL FOREVER BE REMEMBERED AS
A PRESIDENT WHO TRAUMATIZE
LITTLE CHILDREN.
THAT'S HIS BRAND OF NOW.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT THAT
PURPOSELY TRAUMATIZED BABIES AND
CHILDREN, ALMOST CAVEMAN LIKE.
IT'S LIKE FRED FLINTSTONE
RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
DON'T THINK HE HAS THE MORAL
COMPASS TO MAKE A DECISION BASED
ON OUR OWN NATIONAL SECURITY.
ANYONE WHO WORKS ON THE NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM OR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, AT SOME POINT
YOU ARE WORKING FOR A PRESIDENT
WHO IS NOT FIT TO LEAD, THAT'S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN 5
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN M
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN N
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN T
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN ,
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN O
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN E
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN H
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN U
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN R
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN C
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN M
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN E
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN U
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN P
TONIGHT, TOMORROW.
WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED TO HEAR
FROM HIM TO START THINKING 25TH
AMENDMENT OR SOMETHING ELSE?
>> Sean: WE WILL HAVE MORE ON
THIS LATER IN THE SHOW BUT FIRST
WE NEED TO TURN TO BREAKING NEWS
IN FRANCE.
A WIDESPREAD MANHUNT UNDERWAY
FOR THE GUNMAN IN TUESDAY'S
TERROR ATTACK AT A FRENCH
CHRISTMAS MARKET THAT LEFT AT
LEAST TWO DEAD.
NOW THE 2029-YEAR-OLD SUSPECT AS
HE OPENED FIRE BEFORE ESCAPING
FROM THE SCENE IN A TAXI.
WE ARE ALSO LINKS NIGHT HE HAD A
LONG CRIMINAL RECORD AND HE WAS
ALREADY ON THE AUTHORITY'S RADAR
FOR CONNECTIONS TO RADICAL
ISLAM.
SO FAR, FIVE OTHER PEOPLE WITH
TIES TO THE SUSPECT HAVE BEEN
DETAINED AND WHAT'S EVEN MORE
FRIGHTENING IS THAT FRENCH
AUTHORITIES ADMIT HE MAY HAVE
ALREADY SLIPPED ACROSS THE
BORDER INTO GERMANY.
WE WILL KEEP YOU UPDATED AND
PRAY FOR THE VICTIMS, SCARY
TIMES.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, ATTACKS LIKE
THIS, ALL THESE ATTACKS
UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR SAFETY
AND SECURITY LIKE PLACES AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER WHERE WE HAVE
CAUGHT PEOPLE WITH TERRORIST
TIES TRYING TO GET INTO THE
COUNTRY.
WHERE TONIGHT MIGRANT GROUPS ARE
LITERALLY, YOU KNOW, THE ONES,
WOMEN AND CHILDREN THAT THEY
KEPT TELLING US ABOUT.
REMEMBER THEY WERE TRYING TO
MARCH TO THE U.S. CONSULATE,
OVER TIJUANA, DEMANDING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP LET THEM IN THE
COUNTRY?
WELL NOW THEY WANT US TO PAY
THEM 50,000 IN REPARATIONS TO GO
HOME.
PAY YOU TO GO HOME SO YOU DON'T
BREAK OUR LAWS AND DISRESPECT
OUR SOVEREIGNTY?
ONE GROUP ORGANIZER SAID IT MAY
SEEM LIKE A SMALL AMOUNT OF -- A
LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY TO YOU BUT
IT'S A SMALL SUM COMPARED TO
WHAT EVERYTHING THE
UNITED STATES HAS STOLEN FROM
UNDER IS.
WE ALL KNOW THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO COME FROM POOR
COUNTRIES ARE GOOD PEOPLE
SEARCHING FOR A BETTER LIFE.
BUT DEMANDING ENTRY, OR PAY YOU?
OR WE WILL OVERWHELM YOUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM?
THAT'S NO WAY TO ACT TO
DEMONSTRATE MERIT.
IT'S ALSO A MASSIVE SECURITY
RISK.
AS THE SAN DIEGO TRIBUNE IS
WRITING, THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS
ARE UNACCOUNTED FOR.
ABOUT 3500 ARE PRESUMED TO HEAT
HAVE EITHER CROSSED ILLEGALLY
INTO THE U.S. OR MOVE TO OTHER
MEXICAN BORDER CITIES OR SIMPLY
FALLEN THROUGH THE CRACKS WHICH
IS WHY THE PRESIDENT IS STANDING
FIRM, AND RIGHTLY SO, ON THE
BORDER WALL.
FORGING AHEAD ON KEEPING HIS
PROMISE TO THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY TO
PRESERVE OUR NATION'S SAFETY AND
SECURITY FIRST.
REMEMBER, THE WALL WILL HELP
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES BE SAFER
AND THEN OF COURSE, THE WALL
WILL HAVE A BIG DOOR THAT YOU
CAN COME IN LEGALLY.